the Las Vegas sphere has to be one of
the most controversial structures ever
built how exactly did we get here it
looks crazy but we used to build crazy
stuff like this all the time just look
at these images from past world's fairs
people built tons of lavish buildings
adorned with decorative architecture
purely for the spectacle these events
showcase The Cutting Edge of human
Ingenuity incredible building projects
designed to draw attention and highlight
Innovative new technologies the
telephone was introduced at the World's
Fair in 1876
so was the world's first television even
the Golden Gate Bridge was opened at a
World's fair and then we just seem to
stop today we see critical
infrastructure and beautiful
architecture crumbling around us we need
more ambitious projects call it what you
want but it's undeniable that something
very ambitious is happening out in the
desert it's hard to think of a piece of
architecture that has garnered more
attention than the Las Vegas sphere how
can this possibly be real sphere is
ushering in a new era in Las Vegas
mesmerized with the spheres outer
appearance when it comes to the MSG
sphere traffic stops and goes nowhere
this isn't an accident Beyond being the
largest LED structure in the world the
sphere represents something bigger about
our culture the sphere's existence is a
narrative violation in the truest sense
of the term but beyond all the hype
there's a story no one is talking about
and it all revolves around the
concentrated efforts of one man James
Dolan this is a deep dive into The Man
Behind the sphere the struggles that
made him into the magnate he is today
and three actionable lessons to take
into your business career or everyday
life now unless you're an extremely
dedicated basketball fan the name James
Dolan probably means nothing to you that
low profile is not a mistake Dolan is
notoriously standoffish with the press
and he takes great effort to control the
narrative around his work often to his
own detriment if you've read anything
about Dolan you'll get this portrayal
that he's a spoiled rich kid who had
basically everything handed to him well
this is mostly a media narrative it's
also kind of true let's start with his
family history the story of the sphere
doesn't begin with James but rather his
father Charles Dolan or Chuck as he's
known Chuck Was a Serial entrepreneur
but his break came when he dived deep
into the hottest emerging technology of
the day cable television good evening
all week long we've been talking about
the first question to Senator
kened away in full spectrum color with
the rise of streaming Services video
games and social media most young people
don't remember how massive the Cable
business really was but at one point
cable was the business to be in it was
where the startups of yesterday built
their fortunes like many cable was where
Chuck Dolan james' father Stak his claim
and built his family's wealth in 1962 at
the age of 36 Chuck Dolan moved to New
York and established his first business
Tegu Incorporated The Venture was an
early adte play advertisers could
purchase inventory to get their messages
displayed on TVs in all sorts of
locations mainly apartments and hotel
rooms owners of hot tourist spots could
beam their offers to over 44,000 hotel
rooms in the greater Manhattan area this
was huge for the time from this business
he began to build a framework around the
flow of information the ability to pipe
in video content from one place to
another is extremely valuable this idea
would become the theme of Chuck Dolan's
career and make him billions in the
process in the mid 1960s Chuck took this
framework and applied it to a new
business venture but in a more
conventional fashion he founded a cable
network called Sterling Manhattan cable
this was just your typical cable system
with no bells and whistles but it gave
Chuck an important foothold into a
fast-moving industry with lots of
opportunities opportunities like
underground cable in September of 1966
Sterling Information Services Chuck's
holding company partnered with Time Life
Incorporated to found Manhattan cable TV
service the first underground cable
system for the United States for any
cable service today underground cable is
the bread and bu of the business but at
the time this was a groundbreaking
Innovation born from regulatory issues
prior to this television was delivered
via telephone wire and the reception was
usually unreliable especially in
Manhattan with its massive skyscrapers
by putting the cable underground Chuck
was able to effectively deliver service
to almost any business or home in
Manhattan but there were two massive
issues with this plan one putting Cable
in the ground was insanely expensive and
two customers were really slow to adopt
the product due to how new and unproven
cable was at the time with dwindling
revenue and massive Capital expenditures
Chuck needed to make a dramatic change
so in 1969 he merged with time
International to give them more of a
stake in Sterling Information Services
that covered the capex to build the
underground wires so what did Chuck do
about the low demand he came up with an
idea for a TV channel available to Cable
subscribers only building a sense of
exclusivity and value around cable he
initially called it the green Channel
and they aired movies and sports without
commercial Interruption what was one
once the green channel is now HBO you
can thank Chuck Dolan for succession but
we'll get to that later HBO was a
standout success the channel saved the
network and push new subscribers to
embrace cable but not everyone was a fan
of the service you have to understand
the time it was the 1970s and while Paid
Television had been attempted before
this was the first successful iteration
as long as you had a TV and an antenna
you could access all the major broadcast
networks for free so why would you pay
for TV new problems began to emerge on
the horizon for first came The
Regulators these bureaucrats worried
about where they were digging what they
were building and all the downstream
dangers associated with these projects
the FCC had to make sure everything was
up to Snuff and wound up clogging up
every move Chuck Dolan tried to make
then there was also serious competition
from major networks all this work became
a little too much for Chuck so he
decided to take a step back and start a
new cable company cable vision he sold
both HBO and sterling cable Manhattan to
Time Life to fund his new operation and
put his no knows to the grindstone by
this point in Chuck Dolan's story he's
learned the ins and outs of the cable
and media business and so he sets his
eyes on a new Target controlling all of
Manhattan's cable Chuck is one of three
applicants to be awarded cable franchise
permits by the city of New York and
effectively has the rights to the island
he controls the sale of cable in every
corner of every burrow and begins to
build a big bank roll in 2014 their
finances were leaked and they were
making around $6 billion do in Revenue 1
billion in operating income and 3
million in net income while these
numbers are far behind the scale of what
they were making back then cable vision
was an insanely lucrative operation and
became the family's piggy bank they
bought everything from mansions and
Yachts to Madison Square Garden and the
two teams that play Within the arena the
National Hockey League's New York
Rangers and the National Basketball
association's New York Knicks who we'll
get to in a second and here's where we
get to Chuck Sun James Dolan the guy who
actually built the Las Vegas sphere with
lots of money from day one James grew up
with with odd incentives when you have
everything handed to you on a silver
platter what else is there to do what
gives you Purpose with all this Leisure
Time James became an expert sailor
throughout his youth he would take these
massive excursions at one point taking a
70ft 12-man sailboat from Cape Town
South Africa to Rio De Janeiro Brazil
James was a master of sailing and became
deeply embedded within sailing culture
and by extension drinking he attests
that he never drank while actually
sailing but his onland Antics were
enough to raise some eyebrows James
would frequent the yacht clubs and get
torn up as James put it in his own words
the whole sailboat SL yacht racing
culture was around alcohol you go out on
the boat and you come back and get
trashed at the yacht club with your pink
pants and eyes OD shirt eventually James
drinking habit became such an issue he
had to check himself into a rehab center
in 1993 he's been sober ever since and
this is a personal point of Pride for
him aside from sailing Dolan had a deep
interest in music After High School
James pursued a career in professional
music but eventually called it quits and
enrolled in college to get a
communications degree from there he
began to learn the inner workings of the
family business through sales positions
and eventually an assignment to launch a
sports radio station in Cleveland Ohio
James got a crash course on everything
cable vision and began getting involved
in the fight for the family business if
you remember earlier the media always
depicted James as some snobby rich kid
while that doesn't seem that far from
the truth he did have a chip on his
shoulder and a fire in his belly he
wanted to prove himself show everyone
that he had solid business Acumen
[Music]
too 3 2 1 happy New Year in 2003
satellite TV was all the rage shows like
American Idol Survivor and Friends ruled
the airwaves and there were tons of new
companies looking to make Bank on a
better delivery system than cable Market
entrance like Direct TV and Dish had
popped up in '94 and 96 respectively and
were eating up slices of the pie his dad
Chuck noticed this and started investing
heavily into satellites under a new
project called Voom James didn't buy the
hype though and thought it would be
better to invest in actual entertainment
it drove a rift between James and his
brother Tom who was being groomed to
inherit the business and had been
embracing satellite to appease his
father they would argue round and round
about this topic it all came to a head
during meeting with the board of
directors at a restaurant in New York
City tempers flare the atmosphere is
tense and the question on everyone's
mind is who is to take the lead it's
basically an episode of succession after
the dust settles the board made their
decision and sided with Tom and the
satellite TV strategy Voom is funded and
progress is underway rocket launches
infrastructure The Works billions of
dollars spent and in the end it all
fails the internet proved to be a bigger
opportunity and Voom was doomed from the
start the project loses $600 million in
a single year and gets shuttered in 2005
they sell what remains of the division
to echostar Communications Dish's parent
company for $200 million while
disastrous for the company as a whole
this utter failure puts James in a new
light he's not just some rich kid he's a
rich kid with wit this new light
emboldens him to take bigger swings and
James begins to dive into entertainment
now remember how I said the family
purchased Madison Square Garden this
becomes James Dolan's pet project if you
don't know MSG is much more than a
single physical building MSG
entertainment is a parent company that
owns a ton of stuff Radio City Music
Hall the New York Rangers NHL team the
New York Knicks a bunch of radio and TV
networks and James Dolan's personal
Obsession the
Rockets well you may know the Rockets
from the 5 minutes they have on the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade every
year they're much more than just a song
and dance team they're actually an
incredibly sophisticated and vertically
integrated business that anyone can take
notes on every year the Rockets
Christmas Spectacular entertains 1
million people over the course of 7
weeks given the James Dolan owns the
Music Hall and the group he's able to
retain more of the profit this type of
thinking around owning the Act and the
venue also influences his sports
management strategy the only difference
is that sports management is a bit more
complicated also everyone in the sports
world hates James Dolan like they really
hate him I'm so done with James Dolan
who's just a child sell the
team you think I should te you know what
enjoy watching them on TV James no one
is having fun at the Garden except the
fan who went over to you to say sell the
team is not a one-dimensional person the
way he's Port portrayed often in that
he's a complicated guy as owner of the
Knicks James has made many errors one
prominent example is the Lin sanity Saga
let's jump to 2013 the Knicks are riding
high after trying Jeremy Lynn on for
size it was a match made in heaven while
off to a rocky start with very little
playing time Lynn eventually came into
his own and was performing like an
All-Star for New York Lynn secured his
title as a real threat on the court by
scoring 38 points against Kobe Bryant's
Lakers the Lin sanity era had started
Jeremy Lynn was the biggest story in
basketball he was a couch surfing
Harvard grad turned basketball phenom
basically overnight it's a total if you
can make it here you can make it
anywhere type of Story New Yorkers loved
him kids loved him everyone loved him
the Knicks had finally secured a player
they could build a lasting Dynasty
around so what does James Dolan do he
does sign him fans are pissed and for
good reason it looks like James just
doesn't know what he's doing since the
late 1990s the Knicks have had over a
dozen coaches and constant leadership
changes in the past 15 years the Knicks
have had only three playoff appearances
pretty horrific once you realize they
have the highest payroll in the entire
league the Knicks are constantly in
controversy with former players being
arrested and James kicking out fans for
chanting sell the team with this much
bad PR it feels like James is asleep at
the wheel with his interest lying
elsewhere to him Sports is just a
business his true passion is in music as
he said in an interview with the Ottawa
Citizen in 2013 I don't shoot
basketballs I don't shoot pucks I don't
install cable in people's homes music is
a place that goes from my mind to my
hands and into my voice directly so it's
no secret Dolan is a big music fan while
his earlier foray into playing
professionally never panned out in 2005
he started a new band named JD in the
straight shot even though the band isn't
massive they've had a surprisingly
successful run opening for bands like
the eagles the Almond Brothers Band and
zezy top while from the outside it might
seem like just a small pet project for
James he takes it extremely seriously
with a style that's a little bit country
and a little bit rock and roll JD uses
the band as a means of venting about his
life a large portion of the band's
discography is an open diary for Dolan
where he writes about what's troubling
him in his day-to-day life take this
song I should have known the lyrics are
haunting here's a sample I should have
known I should have known I should have
thrown myself across his tracks stopped
him from these VI attacks I have known
if you couldn't pick up the subtext the
song is about his close friendship with
Harvey Weinstein the producer turned sex
offender this passion for music has
driven James Dolan to do many things and
I personally believe it's why he decided
to build the sphere the ultimate
Performing Arts venue it's the
glittering new addition to the Las Vegas
Skyline built for a reported $2.3
billion at 366 ft tall
516 ft wide it's the world's largest
spherical structure that's been called
virtual reality without the headsets
while James has had a lot of things
given to him based on his last name the
sphere is uniquely him James could have
just sat around for the rest of his life
and collected checks from the Dolan
family Empire but he's not he's taking a
lot of risks to build something amazing
and I think that he should be applauded
for but what makes the sphere unique
exactly well at first glance it looks
like a giant LED ball the engineering
and development behind it are much more
than meets the eye the sphere is a
technological Marvel with 700,000
programmable video screens the sphere is
the largest LED structure ever built it
initially just started as a sketch on a
napkin but now it's complete with 19,000
seats 167,000 speakers a structure
that's 10 stories high and a calendar
boasting over 600 events the finished
product is the most advanced
entertainment venue in the world after
we finished construction all that was
left was to outfit the sphere with the
best entertainment
enter You2 in Fall of 2021 the band was
approached to open the $2.3 billion Mega
structure at first they thought it was
going to flop their own creative
director since the 80s Willie Williams
thought it was a terrible idea you had
done massive Stadium tours before but
nothing on this scale if they were going
to launch this structure they were going
to need to dive in deep which is why
they opted for a full-on residency at
the sphere rather than just a single
show while this was a risky bet it paid
off in full with the help of viral clips
and constant media Buzz The Residency is
projected to pull in around $270 million
over 18 dates while that's a significant
amount of money it's nowhere near the
amount necessary to get in the green
after all the massive Capital
expenditures Dolan had to take a page
out of the teleg guide Playbook and opt
for advertising dollars when you have
the most eye-catching structure in the
world you get to name your price to
advertise for just one day on the sphere
you have to Fork over
$450,000 this covers working with msg's
300 plus designers and is estimated to
bring in 4.7 million daily Impressions
across inperson and social media views
some products are perfect for
advertising on the sphere basically if
you sell a spherical product like
something related to tennis basketball
Etc it's going to go viral this extra
monetization angle is critical to making
the extremely expensive investment in
building the sphere pay off while what
you're personally working on may not be
as large as the sphere there are still
actionable lessons from the Dolan family
that you can bring into your own life
and business number one the Monopoly
thesis there are many ways to build
Monopoly you can have proprietary
technology Elite branding Network
effects economies of scale or regulatory
capture after Chuck Dolan sold off
Sterling information to Time Warner he
was given a golden opportunity to be the
only cable provider in New York and Long
Island he chose the path of regulatory
capture understanding its power from his
tie-ups at Sterling this lesson extends
to the sphere the sphere is a
combination of proprietary technology
and Elite branding right now there's
nothing else like it in the world until
there is James Dolan has the biggest
attention grabber in the world building
a direct copy would feel like a knockoff
and in a world of unlimited online
content people are starting to pay more
for real world experiences which are by
definition scarce number two vertical
integration captures untapped value the
rockats and Radio City Music Hall have a
beautiful Synergy since the Dolan own
both they are able to capture even more
value than if the Rockets were a touring
group James is already building this
into his strategy for the sphere by
developing custom content that he fully
owns that that can play in the sphere
forever number three never bet against
someone with a chip on their shoulder
James has always had a reluctance to
speak to the media they smear him call
him a rich kid and talk on and on about
his inherited wealth while any other
silver spooned brat would slink off to
the French Alps and spend the rest of
their life in obscurity James took this
hate and turned it into fuel to Envision
and pull off the sphere is a massive
feat I'd hate to be competing with him
if after learning all this about James
Dolan you have mixed feelings about him
I don't blame you it's easy to see him
as pompous aggressive and petulant you
might be right but there's one thing
that's objectively true James had a bold
and original idea for how entertainment
should be experienced and chased it down
to make it come true he built a
massively ambitious structure that
captured the world's attention and he
did it extremely quickly it's felt
impossible to build new things in the
real world for decades now and even
though the sphere is basically just a
concert venue it's a step in the right
direction thanks for
watching